in this video I want to talk about
glucagon signaling cascade so glucagon
is a hormone that is of a particular
class that particular class is a peptide
or polypeptide so I'll just put here
polypeptide it's about 29 amino acids
long and it is what if you recall
polypeptides are peptide hormones are
categorized as polar hormone so they'll
be acting the systems in which they
would act attached or bind to receptors
that are on the cell surface and
specifically Google will also be part of
a g-protein coupled receptor now
kakugane is released specifically from
the alpha cells of the islets of
langerhans of the pancreas so that the
ductless glands is the pancreas
specifically the alpha cells of the
islets of langerhans so what is Google's
function when you think about gluon you
think oh no glucose is gone so glucagon
responds when the - when glucose is gone
so it respond specifically to low blood
glucose levels so if it's gone make more
so essentially looking on what its role
is it acts on liver cells to increase
blood glucose levels so if your it
responds to low blood glucose levels by
making more so how does it do that well
if it does something Nick I call is this
if you recall glycolysis breaks down
glucose so we want to increase blood
glucose levels do we want glycolysis to
happen no we don't want to break down
glucose we want to stop it so we had
decrease or suppress ah
or 16 fight decreasing glycolysis right
or suppressing glycolysis we want to
stop the breakdown of glucose because we
want to make it so we would increase
gluconeogenesis so goo goo gone
increases blood glucose levels by
stopping the breakdown via electrolysis
and increases the production of it by
active by going through gluconeogenesis
now this does this only on liver cells
not on muscle cells so glucagon via a
g-protein coupled receptor glucagon will
come in and it will bind its g-protein
coupled receptor and the G protein of
course is a stimulatory G protein
initially inactive with this GDP it gets
replaced with a gtp and therefore is
active heads over to adenylate cyclase
it did only cyclase makes a bunch of
cyclic AMP ease from ATP now it'll
activate protein kinase a so it takes it
from a less active state to a more
active State now what do these protein
kinase a is do they're going to act on
tight target proteins to add phosphates
to them now before we start talking
about these target proteins these
enzymes let's review them really quickly
so the target proteins there are P FK 2
and F BP f BP ace excuse me that's a
typo or right o FB pas - so if p FK 2 is
phosphofructokinase 2 so what that does
is that makes F 2 6 BP BP which is
fructose - 6 bisphosphate and I'll go
over that in just a second fructose
bisphosphate ace 2 degrades for justice
bisphosphate so what is fructose to 6
bisphosphate well if you recall the
reason why it's important at least in
our discussion here is that high
fructose - 6 bisphosphate levels
allosteric li activate glycolysis where
as low concentrations of fructose - 6
bisphosphate allosteric we activate
gluconeogenesis now this the second
point here is not something we've
actually talked about but it is the case
this one I this point up here though
however we definitely have talked about
previous videos the allosteric
regulation video on glycolysis now the
other two enzymes here that are
important here are PF k 1 which is
fostered of kinase 1 and the relevance
here is that it's a regulated step of
glycolysis and here fructose
bisphosphate a swan is a regulated step
of gluconeogenesis so that sort of
review that was pretty rapid and quick
but i don't want to spend too much time
on this because this is stuff that we
should that we have already gone over
and I hope that you already know for
this so now let's go through how that
how those proteins are affected in this
cascade so protein kinase a it's going
to add phosphates to things it's going
to add a phosphate to pfk 2 and 2
forjustice phosphatase 2 so it gets
those phosphates from ATP in both cases
so pfk 2 we just said this is the thing
that makes for just 2 6 bisphosphate so
fructose 2 6 bisphosphate is an
activator of glycolysis so we do not
want an activator of glycolysis to be
around 4 glucagon right we don't want to
break down glucose we want to make it so
PF k 2 we want it to be less active so
it starts off more active and we make it
less active okay so in this case adding
the phosphate made this protein less
active but in the case of fructose
bisphosphate ace 2 which is the thing
that breaks down for two
- 6 bisphosphate we went it adding the
phosphate - it went make it go from a
less active state to a more active State
so what's what happens here then if pfk
2 is less active this is the thing that
makes fructose 2 6 bisphosphate if it's
less active that means less frutos - 6
bisphosphate will be made now fructose
bisphosphate ace 2 is the thing that
breaks down 4 toes - 6 bisphosphate if
it's more active that means more
fructose - 6 bisphosphate will be
degraded what's the overall effect of
this less is being made more is being
degraded so that means we're having less
we have a lower concentration of
fructose - 6 bisphosphate now that
fructose - 6 bisphosphate what does that
do well we said that low levels of
fructose - 6 bisphosphate allosteric we
activate fructose bisphosphate ace 1
which is a part of gluconeogenesis so
this is going to be more active so if
this is more active this means an
increased gluconeogenesis which means
more synthesis of glucose okay
this lower frutos - 6 bisphosphate
concentration if there's less of it
around that means there's a lack of
allosteric activation of pfk 1 which is
involved in glycolysis so this is going
to be less active than it normally would
be less active means decreased
glycolysis we have decreased glycolysis
that means we have less breakdown of
glucose we're not breaking down glucose
for energy as much so what's the overall
effect of that well if we're breaking
glucose glucose down less and we're
making more of it we're making more
glucose we have an increased glucose
content
which is what we wanted glucagon to do
so a group of gone does is it lowers
fructose bisphosphate concentrations by
altering the activity of these enzymes
here and that overall this this lower
photo Suzuki bisphosphate concentration
alters the activity of this enzyme and
this enzyme and that is what triggers
the increased glucose concentration
that's the overall process and how it
works as far as how is this signal
terminated same thing as what we did
with epinephrine cyclic AMP II is broken
down to a MP by this particular enzyme
here and the gtp on the G alpha subunit
is hydrolyzed GDP and then the protein
phosphatases remove phosphate groups
from target proteins all of these
contribute to termination of the signal
I hope that video was helpful i'm a
tutor if you live in southern california
feel free to contact me via email at
moose university at gmail.com see the
description below for more details thank
you for watching